سائق قبل انتهاء المهله المحدده اعلم
بنيامينه ياهو الرئيس الاسرائيلي اذاكر
سوك انه نجح في مهمته
اردت ان اخبركم انه بفضل الدعم الجماهيري
الهائل الذي تلقيناه خلال الانتخابات
يمكنني تشكيل حكومه ترعى جميع مواطني
اسرائيل وبالطبع انهي تشكيله في اقرب وقت
ممكن
ائتلافيه خلال الاسابيع السته التي ينص
عليها الدستور مضطره الى طلب مهله اضافيه
انتهت يوم الاحد
لكنها صبت في صالح حكومه يمنيه اكثر تطرفا
من اي وقت مضى من المنتظر ان توكل وزاره
الامن
فير من حزب القوه اليهوديه القوميه
المتطرف الذي وجهت اليه اتهامات بالتحريض
على الكراهيه العامه الماضي
بالتحريض على المظاهرات العنيفه بسبب
استفزازاته المتكرره لسكان العرب في القدس
من حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اليمنيه المتطرف
هو ايضا من بين الاسماء المنتظره سيكون
لحزبه المؤيد للمستوطنين السيطره على
التخطيط في الضفه الغربيه ما يفتح الباب
امام توسيع المستوطنات الاسرائيليه